what is the Republican party going to do
are they going to go this route are they
going to go a more DeSantis route or
another route altogether and of course
Trump was kind of going after DeSantis
this week he had this Ron de
sanctimonious line which kind of fell
flat people weren't into it he sent out
a couple messages on Truth social sort
of going after DeSantis and the question
was is DeSantis ever going to respond in
any way and actually yesterday we've got
the first sort of uh toss-in on that
we would like to know what you think
about trucks big announcement and some
of the less than flattering comments he
has made about you
well you know one of the things I've
learned like learned in this job is um
uh when you're do when you're leading
when you're getting getting things done
yeah you take incoming fire that's just
the nature of it I roll out of bed in
the morning I've got corporate media
Outlets that have a spasm just the fact
that I'm getting up in the morning and
it's constantly attacking and this is
just what's happened I don't think any
Governor got attacked more particularly
by corporate media than me over my
four-year term and yet I think what you
what you learn is all that's just noise
and really what matters is are you
leading are you getting in front of
issues Are you delivering results for
people and are you standing up for folks
and if you do that then none of that
stuff matters and and that's what we've
done we focused on results and
Leadership and uh you know at the end of
the day I would just tell people to go
check out the scoreboard from last
Tuesday night the fact of the matter is
foreign
I mean that's right that's the right
answer right you just keep leading you
know that if you do the right thing
you're going to take fire whether it's
from the media or your political
opponents but then if you do the right
thing you look at that scoreboard and
you go holy cow I just crushed it with a
20-point win and have super majorities
in the house here in Florida where I'm
in DC at the moment but back home in
Florida and we helped a guy like Marco
Rubio with a landslide win and the state
is strong so this again
I like both of these guys I do I very
proudly voted for Donald Trump last time
and it cost me a lot it cost me friends
uh it cost me career opportunities a
whole bunch of stuff there is a
situation in which I would vote for him
again I obviously like the Santa there
is absolutely a situation that I would
vote for him for president
etc etc
the question is what Will trump do if
DeSantis just keeps his eye on the ball
right keeps running Florida keeps doing
all the things that the people want to
do and makes his
his case for his future if he makes it
airtight I am competent and decent I
pick my fights accordingly I secured
elections I don't force people to inject
themselves with things and you know the
machine is going to just keep coming on
him but if he stays disciplined and on a
message I don't know that the attacks by
Trump are going to work
and again maybe there's a way that of
ultimately there's a tag team operation
here I don't know about President and VP
but there might be some way to put these
pieces together but I can tell you I I
definitely sense people if if all Trump
is going to do is throw the kitchen sink
at DeSantis the personal attacks and
whatever else that might be and I heard
a rumor that you blah blah
I don't think that's going to work I
think people are over that and I think
going after people for the personal
stuff you know if if going after people
for the personal stuff destroyed people
any more than Trump would be long gone
right grabbing by the [ __ ] etc etc so
that that's where they'll have to figure
it out I think the other interesting
thing with this is that as I said before
what new voters can Trump bring in that
is it's a really hard question right
that's a hard argument that he's gonna
have to make oh I can bring in all these
people but when you take all the
disaffected Liberals when you take the
ex-democrats when you take the
independence that's a huge group of
people right one of the reasons we
didn't get the Red Wave is because the
independence and the disaffected
Liberals they either stayed home or they
they stayed primarily with the Democrat
Party Ron DeSantis clearly can bring
those people in